like that my I'm going for by somewhere
Tuesday
it's the light
by us well ooh bye hey my 90-day fan
spam its melissia here we're gonna cover
all of this week's happily ever after
drama in just a minute but first we have
to talk about the moment that had my jaw
on the floor the longest it's still
there honestly
okay so who's been up every single night
with both of our sick kids and I'm sick
to do and I woke up sometimes oh my gosh
you freakin liar I'm the one that
planned all of his birthday I do
everything for them it's nowhere near
fair and if it's so easy why don't you
do any of it them just as a woman
talking - I'm gonna feel gorgeous
did I swallow just call Kalani uh [ __ ]
and in front of her mother honestly I
don't think she heard him I really don't
it's either that or he has said this
before as you could see a swell Oh God
really bold with his words during a
family road trip to California to
celebrate their son's second birthday
and here it's his explanation behind all
of his hostility we desert a trip to go
to Samba because Kalani was warrior so
now she wants to take this trip to
California I'm upset because I'm not man
of Towson I swellow is really missing
the point here
isn't he I mean there's a measles
outbreak in Samoa a virus that is
literally killing kids and you have two
of them so a trip to California doesn't
compare to going out of the country and
potentially putting your kids at risk I
get that I swellow is really homesick
and he misses his family but that is no
excuse to throw a temper tantrum and
disrespect your wife Kalani said it
perfectly in this episode she sees now
that I swell
cares more about himself than hiring the
kids I can't wait until she tells her
dad about all of this I swellow was so
upset and annoyed after their big fight
that he left his son's birthday and got
on a bus to go find somewhere to stay
he's following you to the street can you
come here for a second I can't talk
Kalani
don't go chase afternoon I swallow needs
a break let's just give a swivel a break
alright let's just give him some time
okay during this week we also had
another jaw-dropping moment and that
came when Larissa was being messy by
calling chess now Larissa claims that
she's looking out for Jess which she
might be but that doesn't negate the
fact that she was being messy because
she literally told Jess everything she
possibly could to ruin her and Colts
relationship question it's called hiding
is funny for you also Noel you cannot
see what's what do you test
yeah another thing you have over me to
dabby be careful she's a wolf
hey Jessica
colt is a demo yes she can't call a
demon she also called him a geeky player
which at first I doubt it like cool a
player don't really see that but cults
shortly confirmed his player status when
his friend
I'm Vanessa came over more than just
friends had sex with her just a one-time
and honestly I have a crush on her I
think she's a great girl but I don't
think she returns the favor Colt is
saying all of this after he told Ms
Debbie about Jess and she freaked out
and after he were built that he is going
to Brazil to meet justice family I guess
he really is a geeky player huh
by the way miss Debbie invited herself
on that trip to Brazil so she and Cole
will be meeting Jess's family next week
on happily ever after
Angela lands in Nigeria to prepare for
her wedding after her friend offered to
be the witness by going to rent an
apartment sister McGann because one on
stage together see how it looks like and
Kalani's dad catches wind of what's
going on between her and I swellow and
as we probably all assumed he is not
happy when i don't really want to tell
them what's going on but i was clearly
not there I just don't want things to
get alright my 90-day fan spam let's end
it there on that note make sure you
stick with ET because we are covering it
all see you next time
[Music]